cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com it's from the Washington
posts from just the other day Trump hits
new poll highs with Black and Hispanic
voters what to make of it
I love the Washington Post I think
they're typically full of crap they say
either former president Donald Trump
standing in the early uh 2024 polls is
inflated or we are headed for a sizable
realignment in how non-white voters cast
their ballots multiple polls in recent
weeks have shown Trump performing
historically well among Black and
Hispanic voters in head-to-head matchups
with Biden helping put him neck and neck
with Biden away he rarely was during the
2020 matchup
so my question is you guys is it true
and if so why
working class blacks and Hispanics
probably are getting hammered by
inflation more than Yuppie whites right
yeah
this affluent white female Liberals are
probably aren't dealing with the cost of
a family meal at a restaurant yeah when
you know when the cost of a facial goes
up it's probably uh less impactful to
the family budget than like you know
when when you see prices rising at at
the grocery store at the gas station I
think there's there's tax first of all
it absolutely is true all the polls show
they've showed it consistently
um it's both tactically true and
strategically through and I'll tell you
what I mean by that it's tactically true
in the sense of yes they go day to day
I'm paying more my life is not better
now than it was four years ago from a
tactical perspective they absolutely say
we need to see a change
strategically what I mean by that is
first of all Hispanic people and black
people are just generally culturally
more conservative they always have been
they haven't voted that way because the
Democrats sold them you know magic beans
and said look we'll give you a few
dollars and for that you'll vote for us
and and frankly they they bought into it
I think they're now coming around saying
you know first of all a has not helped
me and B all these cultural issues that
I'm against are another part of the
democratic party that I've been
supporting and I think the more we see
these issues like the you know when
people say the radical trans agenda and
they laugh they go what does that even
mean what that means is pretty simple
stuff like look I don't want to see a
child getting medical uh medically
transitioning right I don't want to see
a kid being a takeaway from their
parents I don't want to see a man uh uh
running against females or swimming
against females like that's what we're
taught simple search stuff have you
spoken with anybody I know you're
working on this stuff you do a lot of
men in the street stuff have you have
you done any work around this yet yes so
I are you finding these cultural issues
are coming out in the conversations I
did a video which I haven't released yet
but I'll just the hell I'll talk about
it here spoiler alert yeah spoiler alert
so I I went to a black community college
in LA right all young educated black
kids and I I said let's play a game I
said first of all how do you identify
politically and every single one said
Democrat right without exception every
single one they're young they're
educated and I think I want to play a
game I'm gonna I'm gonna name the top 10
issues facing our country today it was
trans taxes the police the Border all
the issues you think we talk about I'm
gonna say I'm gonna give you the
position of each party but not tell you
which party is which and now you tell me
which position you resonate with the
most out of the 25 kids I talk to not a
single one resonated or majority
Democrat they were all majority
Republican because the issues that they
care about they just don't know they
don't but they're shy give us the issue
that would be the like the biggest
surprise where they want French
Republican oh the big you know what the
biggest one was was on
um on uh so on on on giving money to uh
to their Community I think we're talking
we're talking about spending the
preparations and stuff no no no I'm just
talking about handouts in general yeah
welfare and yeah I was like look by the
way that that is the modern incarnation
of reparations yeah like like to go and
take these programs that were broadly
available and then to put sort of a a
lens of critical race Theory or you know
uh directing those money to to non-white
areas like that is the modern day
reparations that's happening now but you
you say that's you don't think that's a
winning match no no I mean it really
isn't like I said look if you if you see
there has to be an increase in taxes to
pay for more welfare benefits they go I
don't want that don't want it and when I
asked about that yeah they're not
politically voting they're socially
voting yeah
I mean social or cultural it's almost
like oh yeah cultural that's what I mean
yeah it's it's it's political
inheritance right I mean that's what
that's what look my parents did it my
grandparents did it
um and there's also an association
frankly republicanism and white right
there's there's all this like cultural
baggage that they have but if you break
down the issues in the black community
this is what you get right and the
Hispanic Community by the way I think
that having their open border policy I
know that ultimately what was the goal
of the democratic party they want to
change like the Browning of America they
thought that would lock in a democratic
majority for generations and they said
that on MSNBC and all these networks and
then it was called The Conspiracy Theory
or white replacement Theory right or
racism but in reality this is probably
the one of the greatest geopolitical
mistakes Democratic parties ever made
because of Hispanics
are very look they're com they're coming
here and what look like well I think
obviously we need to shut down the
border for any illegal immigrants the
reality is the people are coming are
coming from places they're running away
from what communism socialism things
that have destroyed their party they're
not looking to replicate that here
that's a bit there's a big Florida
Energy around that like there are a lot
of Hispanic voters in Florida that are
saying what the Democrats talk about
sounds a lot like what my parents and
grandparents said they fled from right
and we don't want that here let me
propose an alternate Theory
um and just just for the sake of debate
what if it's just that Trump's the one
that's most persecuted what if you have
a lot of like African-American males who
feel like they you know they are subject
to persecution by the white man and they
see Trump getting persecuted by a lot of
white men and they they identify with
that and they're like you know what
they're chasing that guy I I have some I
have some sympathy for him I have some
desire to be Associated look I
yeah it's an argument
I I I would say it's fair to say that
there's probably some of that I don't
think it's a lot I think there's also a
lot of uh you know look man there are
people who like gold chains and gold
toilets and Donald Trump is the king of
the golden toilet that's like he's he's
but he was that in the last election
what you're seeing in this story is that
it's rising that would ex honestly that
would explain more Trump 2016 because he
was kind of a you know Trump tight right
a rap icon you know Max or uh Mac Miller
wrote the the Trump song and uh now I
think he is known basically more by his
time as president and these these
political prosecutions I I you know why
uh you know why that may be let's say
it's true the reason why I don't like
the argument is because
it just it drives me insane every time
Trump gets in front of a microphone and
he talks about the persecution complex
when I I've said it a million times we
all know this the only words out of his
mouth have to be inflation and
immigration that's it that's it because
that is never going to happen
it's a fever dream I get it if if he
just if he just made a video on a rant
where it was like a very you know you
know I got a friend and they can't
afford to buy they go to the grocery
store and they're spending three 400
bucks a week everyone's gonna hear that
that's those are the viral Tick Tock
memes where you got these 25 year olds
being like here's what we bought a year
ago here's what we bought today and it's
like there's nothing left there there
are young people that are upset about
this and Biden's not talking about it
he's praising by Dynamics in a way it's
it's sort of a Tailwind for us because
because people feel it every day you
almost don't have to talk about it you
know I mean you know what people don't
feel every day the debt yep you know so
you kind of have to talk about it to get
people to think about it but I mean here
oh that's that's the hardest thing man
the the no one's no one pays attention
to the spending bill for the most part
no one pays attention to how the
government is is spending money and what
that means for your savings they don't
understand why interest rates are going
up or how it affects them it's just day
to day but then one day they're like
whoa why is my milk 35 cents more and
then some people might be like it's only
35 cents right and then within a month
or two months now it's a dollar and it's
all related if the government is just
raising the debt limit and spending
money that doesn't exist or printing it
or creating it or fractional reserving
it or whatever then it's devaling all
the currency everyone else has it's
driving up prices and then people they
wonder why it's happening but the one
thing I can say is
I don't think it matters who's in office
when the economy is bad all that matters
of the economy is bad you can make all
the political arguments in the world for
what Biden supports and doesn't support
and he put his name on it the idiot
put his Who the hell's advising this guy
I couldn't believe it it was shocking
he's like he's trying to hand us the
election and we're doing our best to
push it back to him yeah it drives me
nuts it is ripe for the taking let me
ask you a quick come back ask you a
question please okay do you think the
Democrats
the the persecution with Trump and this
pushing of trump was in order to get him
the nomination
or do you think they're they're that
smart and devious they thought look the
more we do this the more we get AMU
Horowitz who might not necessarily
support Trump speaking out publicly for
him because it pisses him off like do
you think they're that smart I don't I I
think that there's there's just a blood
lust with him that will not go away
until he is dead okay and and he will
sort of forever be challenged now you
know had he gone away a matter of
speaking yeah yeah yeah had he gone away
and you know uh played golf at
Mar-A-Lago and not re-entered politics
it probably would have been a lower
level persecution you know making sure
he could never get financing for
business deals making sure he could
never uh you know re-engage on social
media platforms but because he was
running again I think there was a a real
bloodlust for utilization of criminal
law well it's it's he is a comic book
villain for them to fundraise off of
so he's also the he's also the one thing
that unifies their Coalition like what
is the Democratic Coalition without
Donald Trump nothing like they need him
because without like in a weird way
Trump and Biden kind of need each other
yeah right because Trump is able to
contrast directly with Biden on the
economy whereas if you get a Gavin
Newsom it's just you know it's the art
of the imagination and the possible
whereas Biden you have a clear record
run against and I think Biden needs
Trump because this Central argument for
Joe Biden's candidacy is well I'm the
one guy who's beating Trump
I think Joe Biden's gonna drop out so
walk me through walk me through what you
think is the time frame on that and and
the replacement strategy so I don't know
what what I should say is I think there
is a high probability whatever that
number may be that Biden is not the
nominee in 2024. and for for health
reasons or yeah health reasons okay
absolutely absolutely health reasons
no I don't know because it would seem
with all forward-facing information
everything from the news Joe Biden is
going to run again but they know he
can't win was it 70 some odd percent of
Democrats and all these polls say he's
too old dude nobody's running against
him there's two ways to run for office
unopposed and terrified and Joe Biden is
functionally unopposed but they've got
to they've got to bring in Newsome I
mean he's he's their only he Newsome is
substantially better for Democrats than
Joe Biden is Joe Biden recently there
was there was a CBS report I think it
said that he's concerned he won't live
long enough that Hunter Biden's legal
troubles were persist and he may die
soon or something that's his legal
troubles are going to go on for another
40 years for sure but then you had
Washington Post run a story where they
said a democrat in Ohio outright claimed
Joe Biden's death is imminent because of
his old age so when you've got local
Democrats all saying this guy's not
going to last much longer
they certainly have to keep them away
from bicycles he fell off one and stairs
but I mean you've got uh just recently
speaking to the U.N when he said Roger
our institutions and we're just like
what did he say
all it may be the case that Democrats
are just too weak to make the the uh
required stand a statement of everyone
who is in like all Democrat voters we
all know you are concerned about Biden
South and we are formally asking Joe
Biden to step back and allow a new
candidate to stand to stand we'll have a
primary they need to do that I I I I
just can't imagine
with them knowing all of this with all
of the corporate press saying this and
them even calling Now CNN ran a big
segment about Joe Biden being a liar I'm
like these signs don't indicate a Joe
Biden 2024 they indicate not a Joe Biden
2024. thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time